So, we finally got around to testing
Intel's B580, and let's just say it
defied our expectations, and not in the
best way. Roughly 6 months into this
little guy's existence, we wanted to
find out, is Intel doing well with this
GPU thing. Is the B580 worth it this far
into the game, and how does it perform
with older hardware? We got the Intel
limited edition reference card, and
we'll be comparing it to the best value
cards around the same price point we
could find from both Nvidia and AMD.
Those being the RTX 3070 and
RX6650 XT. Before getting into the
numbers, just a few things. The 3070 we
used is the Founders Edition and the
6650 XT is the XFX Swift 210. These
tests were done with an Intel Core Ultra
9285K. And while we normally test 20
games for these comparisons, we're only
using 18 of them this time around as the
3070 was unable to run Indiana Jones at
higher settings due to claimed VRAMm
constraints. But at the same time, the
6650 XT at 8 GB was able to run it fine,
although at a very low FPS. And Halo
Infinite has dropped support entirely
for Intel GPUs. It just straight up does
not run at all on the B580 anymore.
Also, we had a weird issue with GTA 5
Enhanced Edition where it wouldn't
connect to Rockstar's game server
sometimes, which meant we had to
reinstall the Rockstar launcher multiple
times to get all the tests done. Plus,
there were some mild driver issues with
the B580 on our main testing PC, but
uninstalling with DDU and reinstalling
took care of it. This definitely isn't
foreshadowing anything later on. And
another thing to keep in mind is that
both the graphics software and the
drivers are still in their beginning
stages, so don't expect all the bells
and whistles Nvidia and AMD have like
screen capture and audio filtering. Now,
for the numbers, starting with the
price, the B580 was at $250 MSRP, but
now to get a new one, unless you can
snipe an MSRP card from Best Buy or
MicroEnter, you're looking at $320 to
$420, which I was shocked Best Buy sells
the B580. Never knew that. And used
aren't any cheaper on eBay, although you
may be able to get lucky buying in
person locally. The 3070 had an MSRP of
$500 back in 2020 and is currently
sitting at $3 to $400 refurbished on
eBay. And you can even get them for as
low as
$260 used. The 6650 XT is not as widely
available and costs about $350
refurbished or more realistically $220
to $250 used with some going as low as
$184 bucks. Now, when we did all the
testing for this video, the RX960 XT was
being anticipated to cost a little bit
more than AMD announced it at the 299
price point. We may have to revisit this
video a little later on once the RX960
XT drops. However, based on the fact
that the 6650 XT and the RTX 3070 are
priced where they are on the used
market, I don't potentially see AMD
really actually selling their cards for
the prices that they quoted at MSRP. I
could be proven wrong and we'll do a
follow-up video once that card drops.
But, uh, for now, this is how we have
it. So, we ran three synthetic
benchmarks. 3D Mark, Steel Nomad, Steel
Nomad Light, and Passark. In Steel
Nomad, the B580 got a score of 2975. The
6650 XT got 1831, which is the 38% drop,
and the 3070 just barely won with 3,57
points, a 3% bump over the B580. As for
the light version, the B580 got 1101.
The 6650 XT was 20% lower and the 3070
had a much larger win at 18% higher. In
Passmark, the B580 struggled with a 3D
score of only
18,567 compared to the 6650 XT's 14%
better 21,000 score and the 3070 got 40%
better than the B580 to hit 27,000
points. But as we know, synthetic
performance doesn't always translate to
gaming. The only reason we do it is just
so we could have a bevy of benchmarks
that we can compare as time goes on. So,
let's get into the actual game. In the
18 games we were able to test, we ran
four sets of settings. 4K ultra with
mainly quality upscaling. There are a
few native tests mixed in as not all the
games support upscaling. There's 1440
ultra native, 1440 ultra with quality
upscaling, and 1080 ultra native. Note
that all of these have some ray tracing
mixed in as well. For 4K, the B580 got
an average of 50 FPS. The 6650 XT got 39
FPS, which is a 23% drop. And the 3070
got 61 FPS or 21% higher than the B580.
In 1440 native, the B580 got a more
comfortable 65 FPS. The 6650 XT dropped
24% to hit 49 FPS. and the 3070 gained
15% over the B580 to hit 74 FPS. Now,
with upscaling, the B580 hit 90 FPS. The
6650 XT was 75 FPS, which is a 17% drop.
And the 3070 was 101, making it 11%
better than the B580. And then for 1080,
the B580 got 92, the 6650 XT got 75,
which is an 18% decrease, and the 3070
got 101, which is 10% better than the
B580. And finally, the total combined
averages come out to 59 FPS for the 6650
XT, 74 FPS for a plus 25 difference for
the B580, and 84 FPS for the 3070, a 13%
gain over that B580. Using these numbers
of all the testing, we get a dollar per
frame cost of
$3.36 at MSRP or
$4.32 straight price for the B580. 6650
XT costs
$6.73 MSRP or
$3.88 street pricing and the 3070 is 595
MSRP or
$3.58 street pricing. Now, regarding 1%
and 0.1% lows, for those of you who
aren't familiar, the closer the lows are
to the average FPS, typically the
better. And the bigger the difference is
from the average FPS, you'll get more
stutters and less consistent of an
overall experience. And the B580 really
struggled with an average of 39 FPS at
1% lows and 18% FPS at.1% lows as
opposed to the 6650 XT which had 38 FPS
for the 1% lows and 29 for the.1% lows.
And the 3070 was better still for 53 FPS
with the 1% lows and 36 for the.1%. And
although the 3070 is the better
performing card overall, especially in
more intensive loads, including rage
racing, the gap isn't as big at 1080p,
only 10% better, which is where it
matters most, as that's most likely what
you'll play at. And though the averages
may not demonstrate it in six of the 18
games, the B580 matches the 3070s
performance or even slightly beats it.
The B580s uh Founders Edition limited
edition also runs cooler at 55 to 60
degrees Celsius and takes a good bit
less power at 140 watts than the 3070 65
to 75° C and 190 watt power draw. So,
it's more forgiving to anyone upgrading
an older system who may not have as big
of a power supply, but we'll get into
more of the older system upgrade info in
a minute. The 6650 XT is lackluster in
all of this. Having that average
negative 20% performance of the B580 and
using the same amount of power at 140
watts and with our card running hotter
at 65 to 75°C, it's pretty clear that
these are going to be mainly 1080p cards
with 1440 capability in some titles or
with upscaling. And while the B580 is a
bit behind the 3070s performance, it
does still have three main things going
for it. One, the B580 is currently less
than a year old compared to the 4
1/2year-old 3070, so it should be longer
before it runs out of support, but then
again, specific game support for it
might just end like we saw with Halo
Infinite during our testing. Two, the
B580 is currently still being produced,
so you can get one new for as low as
$320, meaning you don't have to worry
about not having a manufacturer's
warranty or the many other risks of
buying used. such as how the card was
used, mining, gaming, overclocking,
general environment, care with pets,
smoking, scams, etc. And then number
three, it has 12 GB of VRAM instead of 8
gigabytes, which is becoming an issue in
newer games at ultra settings. But most
of the time, you'll run into a
performance issue of being able to run
those highest settings before VRAM stops
you. A notable exception is Indiana
Jones where the 3070 will not run at
ultra settings whereas the B580 can run
at 1440p ultra native at 59 FPS or 1080p
at 72fps. Now, we did want to address a
major common concern with the B580, the
overhead on this card and it being
bogged down by an older CPU. We put it
in an AM4 build with a Ryzen 5 2600. And
while we expected it to not perform as
well, what we actually got was a slew of
graphics issues. Keep in mind, I can't
exactly say how universal of an
experience this is. But when we booted
it up with a fresh install of Windows,
everything was fine until we installed
the graphics drivers. After that, the
screen immediately started flickering
and going black for around 2 to 15
seconds at a time. wouldn't let us turn
up the refresh rate to match the monitor
and sometimes it wouldn't display out at
all and we had to do multiple restarts.
It was actually a nightmare. After a day
plus of headaches and troubleshooting,
we were able to get it working for a
time, but not at all consistently,
during which we did test a few games,
getting anywhere from the same results
as we did with the 285K all the way to
losing 50% of its performance. We ended
up switching to a Ryzen 3600, which
still had a couple bugs, mainly on
startup, but was infinitely more
manageable and consistent, which allowed
us to get even more numbers to throw out
your face. In 3D Mark's test, it lost
less than 1% of performance. However, in
Passmark, the 3D score took a massive
33% hit. But for actual gaming
performance, it went from 50 FPS down to
45 in 4K, losing 11% of its frames.
1440p native went from 65 down to 55
which is a loss of 15%. 1440p with
upscaling got down to 66 fps from 90
which is a 27% drop. And finally in
1080p native performance went from 92
fps to 66 a 28% difference. Keep in mind
your experience will vary as these are
averages and performance highly depends
on the game as at 1080p performance was
anywhere from 10% better in F124 down to
59% worse in Balders's Gate 3. Suffice
it to say, if you are rocking an older
CPU, it's not going to be as good. It's
just that simple. So, to recap, the 3070
has an average of 13% better performance
at right about the same cost or a little
cheaper, albeit it won't be new. The
B580 beats the 6650 XT by an average of
25%, but has 31% worse 0.1% lows. That
That's a lot of percentages, but
hopefully you understand. The B580s
graphics drivers definitely have issues,
especially in older systems, but we can
hope they get better as more updates
come out. That's what happened with the
Alchemist cards at least. And it has
been slowly trickling out with things
like their Lunar Lake handhelds. They've
been updating Battle Mage in that
regard. And upgrading an older PC is a
real tossup, but not a bad option
depending on the games you play and if
you're willing to sacrifice your time
and previously migraine-free brain to
the troubleshooting gods. If your PC
qualifies for a Windows 11 upgrade,
you're probably in the clear. I'd highly
recommend you be on something like a
Ryzen 5 5600 before you even consider
being on the Intel graphics card at this
point. So, overall at the $250 MSRP,
this could be a good buy if you're
experienced with PCs. But with
affordable B580s being almost constantly
sold out, you're more realistically
spending $320 to $400. And that's a lot
harder to justify when the 3070 is such
a good value right now. And we also
don't know how the 960 XT is going to
hit the market. But as shown, the B580
does beat the 6650 XT by a good margin.
So if you're looking to get away from
Nvidia on a budget, this could be the
one to go for. Or again, until AMD drops
the 960 XT, which again I don't think is
going to cost the MSRP that they're
saying. And so more than likely the 960
is going to be the $300 card. But maybe
I'll eat my words and uh we'll do a
follow-up.